okay so let's move on now he was kind of
the first to to give to kind of bring
this concept to light but the person who
really shut down logical positives
single-handedly was my favorite
philosopher uh by the name of Thomas
Kuhn you saw his quote in the beginning
and he is perhaps one of the most
influential people
in the world today he died uh of course
in um very recently
uh but he is not very he's not spoken
about very much
um but he is very influential in all
fields of knowledge
and he has done a lot for the world in
terms of understanding of Science and
our understanding of just of just
reality
um and he was basically he was a
historian
um but he came up with the scientific
theory
and uh I was going to read his profile
here Thomas another American
pragmatist who attended the same
University as Quine and was subsequently
be influenced by the latter uh typo
Advance the idea of the holistic
understanding of knowledge in his famous
work the structure of scientific
revolutions and I believe in the
introduction to this course or this
module I gave this book as pre-reading
material
made three major points at his
analysis of scientific scientific
history the first is that science
operates based on paradigms
everyone in this room I think knows the
word Paradigm guess what this guy Thomas
Kuhn is the one who coined the term
he's the one who came up with the word
so you guys saying oh this is the
Paradigm this Paradigm you see people in
the media talking about paradigms
him
he's the reason
okay
the first is that science operates based
on paradigms or holistic culturally
inherited theories that help us to make
sense of experiences
so a paradigm is basically a world view
like the Islamic worldview is a paradigm
okay
uh the second is that most applied
science that makes anything close to
progress what he calls normal science is
mainly about solving puzzles within a
given Paradigm so
what he says is that all the science we
do today like you see people doing
experiments they're working they're
operating by a certain paradigm
okay a certain Paradigm about reality
certain Paradigm evens like subparadigms
like a certain understanding of how
physics works right like today we we
have something called quantum physics
scientists work within that Paradigm of
physics okay
and he would say that these people are
doing normal science so they're working
within this little Paradigm they're not
challenging the Paradigm they're working
within it so all the experimentation all
the academic articles all the research
is done within a specific Paradigm even
in biology evolution is what it's not
just a theory it's also a paradigm
okay
um
and third there are Paradigm shifts or
revolutions which result from normal
Sciences inability to solve the
anomalies faced by an established
Paradigm what does this mean
okay basically you found out that
um
once a paradigm becomes very successful
say Evolution or
something else gravity things like this
what happens eventually is that uh there
are some problems
scientists begin to observe things that
are not normal
meaning that they're not in accordance
with the paradigm
meaning that uh they don't work as they
should like if a paradigm says it should
be like this
for some reason something they've
observed does something completely
different and they're like okay why does
this happen and they start to encounter
more and more of these issues like the
more data they collect the more the
anomalies or the the changes the
differences become more and more like
strenuous to the theory
so the theory becomes heavier and
heavier it becomes more convoluted more
complex and the scientists keep tweaking
the theory like they keep changing
little parts of it saying okay well
um
a good example is evolution so for
example you know it was kind of simple
in the beginning and now they're kind of
giving more explanations to it to try to
explain some things they keep finding
that aren't going to plan you know what
I'm saying so they keep tweaking things
uh and they keep saying well you know
there's an issue here so we got to
change this let's move this around maybe
it's not like this so let's change the
theory a little bit like this and and
this keeps going and going until finally
somebody sits down and goes hey guys uh
this is way too complex now and I think
it can be more simple than this and they
go okay here's a new paradigm boom this
is more simple this solves all the
problems let's switch to this
and there's historical examples of this
happening this is the reason it came up
with this is because his primary example
was uh let's see new question
okay Ahmed Faraz like for example the
Tree of Life becoming a web of life is
that a tweak in the theory yes it is
common ancestry theories have been
changing dramatically
because they keep finding things that
don't go to plan
see what I'm saying
now this happens within every major
Theory to be honest it doesn't mean
we're going to talk about what the
theory is in a moment it doesn't mean
that the theory is wrong okay it just
means that the theory is not entirely
able to explain the data
um
Okay so
let's keep going though so for example
his his example was he looked at the
ptolemic system and the uh the system
copernican system so heliocentric versus
geocentric okay geocentric system was
basically what
um
the Earth was the center of the Galaxy
the universe right
idiocentric the sun is a center right
okay
um so what happened this was a paradigm
shift and what happened was that Ptolemy
he explained the universe in this way it
was basically like the the planets and
everything in the sun were rotating on
the earth and sometimes the the Motions
of the earth of the planets would be
kind of erratic it'd be kind of weird
so he explained it like okay it must be
that way because not only are the
planets and the Sun going like this but
they're also kind of going like this
right like little circles okay epicycles
I think I have a diagram let me show you
boom there it is it's horribly horribly
blurry okay so the GEOS on your system
is here and if you can see on the left
side so basically all these planets in
the sun would rotate around the earth
not just in one circular fashion but
they would do epicycles
so Squig leaves
and one day uh a lot of scientists came
along and said even from the Islamic
tradition by the way
mainly the first people to question the
ptolemic system were were
scientists from the from the uh from the
Islamic tradition
like
who was the first one to advance the
idea that the Earth was not stationary
and actually in actuality it rotated
um so Copernicus got a lot of his ideas
from Muslim philosophers and Muslim
scientists
and uh eventually what happened was that
all of these problems kept adding up
like there was just too much stuff like
why is it this complicated and we still
can't understand why the planets are
moving in certain ways like there's like
Venus and Mercury we're still kind of
acting weird you know so why
this epicycles there's going to be
another problem so they kept trying to
add more things and it just got more and
more confusing and then eventually
somebody said you know I have an idea
maybe instead of putting the Earth in
the center let's put the sun in the
center and see how it how it works and
guess what all those little squiggly
lines went away
and then uh scientists were like hmm
this makes more sense and they adopted
the heliocentric system
now according to many atheists today the
only way to understand
or to to justify a theory or to justify
in a way something works is if it's
directly observable
you know if you can actually see what's
going on like basically
Copernicus would have to go up into
space and like observe
directly this phenomenon but he didn't
he he only proposed this Theory because
why because it was to solve let's go
back to solve the issues with uh the
televic system the geocentric system
so Thomas was uh when he published
his work he was very famous for it and
he changed the way in which we
understood science is not being this
gradual process of events of data
collection and theories building upon
each other uh he also revealed that
um that knowledge was holistic it wasn't
reducible to like logical axioms like
just observable phenomenon and that in
fact theories were not direct
representations of the world that we
know it theories in a way were more or
less like commentaries or explanations
about how the data should look
so they say you have all this data all
this observational data that you have
and what he said was basically a theory
is just taking all that data together
and trying to make it fit like a puzzle
in the right places
that's it
and um
the best the way I like to to find a
theory is as a tuxedo okay a theory a
scientific theory essentially to the
scientific Community is what we consider
to be a tough Seer okay
to the scientific Community a theory is
a tough seer
to the world
okay
um
now
essentially then science is not
does it accurately depict all of reality
no because every theory has its own
share of problems which we eventually
have to correct right and every theory
has a new model for things so how can it
be progressing if every new theory is
different from the last one right it
doesn't it doesn't take from it it
literally is a different thing like the
geocentric system was the Earth was the
center right and then this heliocentric
the sun was the center that's completely
different paradigm
correct
so it's not Progressive it's not even
realism it's not even tied to reality
because the theory itself is only
constructed to make sense of what we see
it doesn't actually explain the exact
representation
of reality itself if that were the case
then Copernicus would have never come up
with this Theory right he he literally
was sitting at a desk when he came up
with this Theory
how did he do it if he had to directly
observe what was in front of him if it
was reality itself you know that he was
observing
no he didn't he came up with it in his
mind uh to solve these dilemmas
so this was essentially the end of
positivism at that point unfortunately
um it was only the end of positivism and
scientism
in the academic sense
okay so Anonymous attendee is can we say
that naturalism is a paradigm Indore
winning evolution is a physical
explanation of the reality
uh the Paradigm is to explain everything
without invoking the Divine yes we can
but naturalism is a sort of a meta
paradigm
the naturalism was a paradigm and we
could say that darwinian Evolution I
just prefer to say Evolution because
we've moved quite a long ways since
Darwin
um The evolutionary theory now is is not
very similar to Darwin's
um I mean similar in some respects but
they've changed a lot
uh so Evolution would be a theory
um
a theory a physical explanation of the
reality that we see but it's not the
reality
um so it's not a realistic now people
who follow scientism will say this and
we're about to debate that in a moment
uh because if if you've already if
you've been following this history
you'll see that at all uh basically
destroyed this understanding of science
already
so why is it still here okay well we're
going to explain that especially why is
it among atheists well you see when
something is destroyed in the academic
arena when something is debated in the
academic arena it doesn't always
transfer to the society
especially today
um not only that but atheists were the
first ones to sort of come back and
revive scientism
and we're about to find out who did
who was the first one to do it
okay so let's see who's next Anthony
flew who knows Anthony flew I'm sure a
lot of you do you might have read his
books
um he is a famous philosopher in the
1970s atheist who became a deist because
he believed in the so-called scientific
miracles of existence uh that led him to
believe in God
and uh he eventually wrote a book about
it and then he passed away in 2010.
um he was a also very Charming
individual a very good person uh a very
good philosopher but he came up with
something very interesting I don't know
if you've heard all this but you're
about to find out also George Smith came
after him and then you have uh Sam
Harris Richard Dawkins Christopher
Hitchens and Victor stenger
so this is the isnag
okay we're about to complete our islad
right
Anthony flew
possibly the most famous atheist of the
20th century would who would later
eventually become a Diaz was the first
to construct the idea yes there is a God
there is a God was the name of Anthony
food's book
see you guys know you just never knew
the history huh
I'm connecting all the dots for you now
uh before we go on another uh comment
Anonymous attendee can we bet it can we
still benefit from theories if they are
not so definitive yes of course
we can
um because the data itself is still true
what we observe is still a thing how we
interpret it is the issue
okay so a commentary can assist you
uh in reading the Quran for instance
right but there are still differences of
opinions within those commentaries
you see what I'm saying okay
so here we go
um
let me continue reading with with
Anthony flu
possibly the most famous atheist of the
20th century would later eventually
become a DS was the first to construct
the idea of weak negative and strong
positive atheism the former which he
promoted as the presumption of atheism
and uh his reason for the construction
of these labels are as followed
what the protagonist of the presumption
of Atheism in my sentence wants to show
is that the debate about the existence
of God ought to be conducted in a
particular way
and that the issue should be seen in a
certain perspective his thesis about the
onus of proof involves it evolves it is
up upon the
it is up to the theist first to
introduce and to defend his proposed
concept of God and second to provide
sufficient reason for believing of his
concept of uh of his does in fact have
an application
okay uh translation
you know how atheists tell you today
that uh they lack a belief in God
he's the one he's the reason this is the
reason
uh he did not change uh another question
did flu change his mind on the
presumption of atheism once he became a
deist no he did not
in fact he followed this presumption and
that's why he became abused I don't
actually agree with the reason he became
a deist by the way just throwing it out
there but he was very consistent with
his principles
um as somebody who has studied the
philosophy of science I we're gonna we
can discuss this at a later point I am
not a fan of
believing in God on the basis of
so-called scientific miracles
I think that is a false understanding
of how to come to God's existence
that's all I'll say
um we can discuss at a later point but
I'm just giving you a clue as to write
because if you understand what science
is you will not come to that conclusion
right
okay we'll discuss that later
so anyways he said that basically
um
he came up with the idea of lacking
belief in God he said atheists don't
they're a strong atheist positive
atheists who believe that God doesn't
exist but they're also weakness or
negative atheists like myself and other
people that's what he said
her most atheists who just lack a belief
therefore the default position is
atheism and you have to prove to us
that God exists that's what Anthony flew
came up with
James calls it the presumption of
atheism
now another philosopher came along
now Anthony flew by the way did not
assume that the presumption could be met
through science alone he believed that
philosophical inquiry or philosophical
argument could also be used to prove
God's existence but somebody else came
along another philosopher who followed
his lectures and decided to revive
scientism as a result of this
his name was George Smith
is not very well known but he's the
reason for everyone else below him
okay George Smith another atheist
philosopher who was influenced by
Anthony food's new understanding of
atheism would Advance the latter's ideas
in such a way that he would provide the
foundation for contemporary atheist
thoughts if you want to know why
contemporary atheists believe what they
believe today
he's your man
he's not like I said he's not well known
but I have I have searched far and wide
for the persons who gave and for the
people who gave the ideas to Sam Harris
Richard Dawkins Etc and this is him
okay
uh like I said this is why you should
study history and the philosophy of idea
and philosophy of history and things
like this because then you can figure
out where these where these ideas are
coming from
uh where flu might except philosophical
argument to opposes presumption of
atheism Smith believed that it was
impossible to do so and I quote from his
book atheism the case against God
probably his only published work
naturalism has the priority over
supernaturalism not because it is the
more economical of two explanations
but because it is the only framework in
which explanation is possible the
contest between naturalism and
supernaturalism is not a battle between
two rival modes of explanation
naturalism is the only context in which
the constant of explanation has meaning
what does that sound like
logical positivism
but instead of saying that the statement
has no meaning
until it's empirically verified what
he's saying is what an explanation has
no meaning unless it's empirically
verified
what does lacking a belief even mean
that's a good question
um what does lacking a belief mean
uh to give you a brief
lacking belief
um can be meant in two ways a lack of
belief can be meant as having no
awareness of the belief whatsoever
like being a rock or a tree
or like or being a baby even
um
I mean even the babies have fitra but
they don't really comprehend God you
know they don't understand what that
means they have an inclination towards
it but they don't you know a baby's born
they don't understand God like we do
uh or lack of belief can mean that I
just don't believe it because I don't
have a reason to I a suspension of
judgment is usually how atheists
referred referred to as is a lack of
belief is a suspension of judgment I I
just don't know
so
you know like if I say I don't know
basically it's their way of saying I
don't know is I lack the belief
it can be used as a defense mechanism
now if you want to get really deep into
it
um
so Abu Faris what are your views on
negative atheism as an intellectual
position does it have intellectual
cogency or is it simply an obfuscation
uh it is a position
in the sense in the sense of being a
state of being but not as in like a
proposition itself
um and I was about to explain what I
mean by that in a moment
so for example if I lack a belief in God
there has to be a reason for that right
not just because I'm unaware because I'm
obviously aware of God or the concept of
God if I say I lack of belief in God
right
uh so what does it mean to lack a belief
in that sense it means that well I don't
have evidence
or I don't have a reason right so there
now you're seeing positive beliefs
it's no longer a negative belief now
it's a positive so the lacking itself
might be negative but the positive
aspects there are positive aspects
behind it you can't lack something
without having a reason for it right
like if I say I lack a belief in Bigfoot
and somebody says why I'm going to tell
you well I don't have evidence there's
no reason for me to right but then you
can ask other questions well what do you
mean by evidence
what do you mean by reason
right lacking a belief doesn't make you
rational by default and I wish actually
I had a video I was going to show you
but I thought it would take too long and
I've been talking so much taking up so
much time so we're not going to see it
anyway
but uh
let me give you an example
flat earthers people who believe in a
flat Earth they lack belief in that the
Earth is round
there you go but nobody calls them
rational
I wonder why
um
so but there are but there are reasons
why they lack a belief right because
they don't understand science maybe they
don't understand what they're asking for
in terms of evidence in the same way I
treat atheists like this I treat
atheists like they're flat earthers I
consider them the The Meta the
metaphysical flat earthers okay like
they always ask well there's no reason
to believe in God
my my I don't I don't try to provide
reasons to them then I don't provide
evidence because you know what I first
do I question their reasons I question
why they lack of belief most people
don't do that these days first thing
they do is they go straight to the
arguments like uh Hamza was telling you
you know to go on the defensive right no
if you're if your skepticism is
ridiculous there's no reason for me to
to answer you if you tell me for
instance I lack belief that this is
reality
what am I going to do
you know
you want me to answer that that's
ridiculous that's nonsense you know
there's a certain proposition a certain
certain forms of skepticism that are
just nonsensical what would be the point
of even going into it the same way I
treat atheists they hate it when I do
that because they feel like they're so
Superior intellectually but with their
understanding of science when they say I
want evidence for God's existence
through scientific inquiry and I say do
you understand science because
you wouldn't be asking me that question
if you did
Anonymous attendees what is the
difference between positive and negative
atheism as I've already said
negative atheism is a lack of belief it
means that I don't have
I I am I don't know
if I believe or not it's sort of like
agnosticism okay
and then um in fact it is agnosticism
but this would replace it later
so flu eventually would say narcissism
is nonsense it's just a form of atheism
it's a negative atheism and positive
atheism or strong atheism is basically I
do not believe God exists meaning that
there's a firm belief that God does not
exist
okay there is a difference between those
two
there's a major difference
another question why uh by not
understanding Islamic and why is
naturalism considered Superior to
supernaturalism
because according to I don't believe
that but according to Smith it's because
it's the only context in which we can
understand anything
you look around the world you don't see
it in Supernatural
right you don't see God you don't see
Angels you don't see Jinn you don't see
anything you only see what grass trees
my house you know the computer screen
that's all you see so according to Smith
because that's your only point of
reference that makes it Superior
according to Smith
now I actually have arguments against
Smith's arguments more detailed ones on
my
website.com you can go on there and find
my article I'll probably link it later
in the
course module
introduction I didn't think we're gonna
get into the discussion but where I
basically show why his argument is false
um I go into more detail and I I prove
that it's wrong I'll give you a concise
format here basically he says that
because this is the only context in
which we live
that we can't presume that there's a God
right I actually accept his argument and
I say this I say okay well if that's
true if it's true that this is the only
point of reference that we have then in
fact you're wrong because then we
shouldn't even think about God there
should be no mention of God that a whole
concept of God shouldn't even come into
our minds if this is all we can perceive
and understand
if this is the only context in which we
can explain anything the concept of a
Transcendent being who is beyond the
physical characteristics of the natural
world shouldn't even pop into our minds
that's my explanation or my argument
it's sort of like a reverse ontological
argument
I think it's very good but whatever
that's not the point of this lecture
you guys can judge it for yourself
excuse me
so he revived the sort of scientific
understanding and verificationism
through the idea of explanation instead
of statements having instead of
statements requiring meaning in order to
be uh
I'm sorry instead of statements
requiring verification physical
phenomena in order to have meaning he
instead said explanation so now it's no
longer self-reputing
okay
um but there are some major problems
with it
uh
uh Anonymous attendees like do you
believe atheists actually exist or do
you believe they don't exist in the true
sense
I believe that everyone's upon the pitra
so I believe that atheists are going
through cognitive dissonance and in fact
this is a proven fact if you look up
any study on the nature of belief today
there are only two types of people
who are atheists in the explicit sense
one normally mentally healthy
individuals who continuously remind or
continuously reminded of the natural
inclination to believe that there is
purpose and design in the world
okay the atheists will complain
themselves about this like oh they even
talk like this they feel like there's
like they always talk like there's
purpose out there they can't get rid of
it
um you see a lot of articles online in
this respect as well it is complaining
about this natural inclination uh but
those are sort of write it off and say
well it doesn't prove anything it's just
that's just an evolutionary trait that
I've you know that I've that I have
because my ancestors you know developed
this thing because you know to to warn
themselves of predators around them so
they saw intention and purpose
everywhere things like this so that's
what it is that's the reason it came
about so they're trying to explain it
through some sort of evolutionary like
byproduct
and then you have another group
which is uh basically people with autism
or Asperger's is one of the two I'm
sorry I'm not thinking very clearly
right now but somebody people with
mental deficiencies in certain regards
have difficulty who people who have
difficulty empathizing or sympathizing
with others or understanding human
emotion they tend to be atheists very
easily people who are very technical
I think it's Asperger's or is it hot
system or whatever
they tend to be more inclined
towards that and uh you can actually see
this on the online world as well
if you notice
um I think it's Asperger's yeah
some people are pretty much borderline
Asperger's because if you notice how
people interpret scripture they do it in
such a way that it's almost like they
can't understand metaphor they can't
understand context they can't understand
holistic understanding of the text
and they tend to be atheists
so when you wonder why atheists like the
cherry-pick passages from the Quran and
present them
and like you know like this
matter-of-fact way it might have more to
do
with them having a certain
condition I'm not saying all of them but
there are there might be a sizable
minority that are like that and there
are studies out there that show that
people with Asperger's
and even autism I think uh are more
prone to the atheists and these are some
of the traits they have so they read
everything very literalistically
so just something to remember something
to uh to note
all right so
okay so George Smith was the one to
revive scientism among society and
especially the atheist Community we have
about 25 minutes here and I want to save
some time some more question answers so
we'll really get to the end
and uh maybe even explain some Islamic
history as well I gave you guys an
article in the introduction that you can
read